We may define the task of
diagnosis as determining
what is wrong with
a malfunctioning device.
Or more generally, what is
the fault that is responsible for
a malfunctioning system.
Given a system,
we expect some behavior from it.
We expect it to do something.
However, we may observe that the system
is doing something different.
So there is the expected behavior and
there is the observed behavior, and
there is a discrepancy between them.
When there is a discrepancy, we know
that the system is malfunctioning.
The question then becomes
what is the fault or
the set of faults responsible for
the malfunctioning system.
When we think of diagnosis we
typically think of medical diagnosis.
But, of course diagnosis can occur
in a very large number of domains.
Here are three diagnostic domains
with which all of us are familiar.
The first figure shows
the engine of a car.
When I insert the key into the ignition
system, I expect the engine to turn on.
That is the expected behavior.
But suppose that I insert the key,
and the engine doesn't turn on.
That's the observed behavior.
There is a discrepancy between
the expected behavior and
the observed behavior.
When I insert the key into the ignition,
I expect the engine to turn on.
That's the expected behavior.
But then suppose that I put the key in,
and the engine doesn't turn on.
That's the observed behavior.
The discrepancy between the expected
behavior, turn the engine on, and
the observed behavior,
the engine doesn't turn on, so
I know there is a malfunction.
Given this malfunction,
the question becomes what is at fault,
the force responsible for it and
that's the diagnostic task.
To address this diagnostic task, I may
use a rule which says that if the engine
doesn't turn on when the key is
inserted, check the carburetor.
Suppose I go and
check the carburetor and
everything is okay with the carburetor.
Then I [INAUDIBLE] get activated.
And let me say,
if the engine doesn't turn on and
everything is okay with the carburetor,
go check the spark plugs.
And this way, I am going to use
a production system to isolate the fault
of faults responsible for
the malfunction.
>> Something similar happens
with computer hardware repair.
When we turn on a computer, there
are few behaviors that we expect of it.
We expect it to boot up quickly,
we expect it to run fast, and
we expect it to stay cool.
Now, imagine we turn a computer and
notice it started to run at a much
higher temperature than
we're accustomed to.
We might remember that the last
time we encountered this problem,
there were problems with the fan.
So we might use that to then diagnose
this a problem with the fan and
replace the fan.
This happens at the software level too.
If I'm writing a program and the output
differs from what I was expecting,
I set about debugging the program and
finding the fault.
One way of doing that is called
a rubber duck debugging, which involves
explaining my model of how my program
works to the rubber duck so that I might
uncover the error by forcing myself
through an explanation process.
>> Note that we discussed
the same diagnostic task
in three different domains.
In each domain there was a discrepancy
between the expected and the observed
behaviors and we tried to identify
the fault, or faults responsible for it.
Note also that we alluded to three
different methods for doing diagnosis.
The matter of rule based reasoning,
the matter of case based reasoning,
and the matter of model based reasoning.
We haven't talked a lot about the matter
of model based reasoning so far.
We will do so when we come to
systems thinking later in the class.
Of course we can use the matter of
rule based reasoning, not only for
diagnosing car engines but also for
repairing computer hardware or for
diagnosing computer software.
In this particular lesson our focus
will be on the diagnostic task.
By now all of us are already
familiar with many reasoning methods
that are potentially
applicable to class.